[Musique]
ce débat en fait l'absence du débat
est-ce que le Canada devrait
mener ce débat c'est-à-dire faire un
référendum est-ce qu'on doit couper nos
liens avec la Couronne britannique oui
ou non par contre on la remplace etc je
vous ai montré tout à l'heure je vais
vous les remontrer si vous le voulez
bien des chiffres d'un sondage ça va
peut-être étonner des gens c'est pas
juste au Québec où les gens se disent
peu attachés à la monarchie britannique
diriez-vous que vous êtes
personnellement attaché à la monarchie
oui 19% dans tout le Canada c'est un
Québec mais dans tout le Canada 12% au
Québec donc plus bas sans surprise et
non quand même 77% dans tout le Canada
87% des Québécois se disent pas tâcher
ou sans doutait évidemment la monarchie
britannique je ne sais pas bon
il l'arrivée du roi Charles
ça améliore pas les choses bonne
nouvelle 15% indifférent les gens sont
indifférents dans tout le Canada alors
il n'a pas Laura d'Elizabeth de je me
tais je vous écoute est-ce qu'on peut
ouvrir ce déballage ou faire entendre
monsieur Trudeau tout à l'heure mais je
veux votre opinion rapidement est-ce que
comme d'autres l'ont fait avant nous
d'autres pays ce qu'on devrait ouvrir ce
débat Émilie je pense que dans les pays
du commonwald qui ont encore la
monarchie britannique comme chef d'État
le Canada et le pays qui va sûrement
ouvrir ce débat en dernier
l'Australie a déjà eu un référendum sur
la question qui avait été perdu de peu
pour faire donc de l'Australie une
république il y a encore un gros
Mouvement Républicain organisé là-bas en
Nouvelle-Zélande aussi on parle de ces
questions là de la Barbade dans les
entiers qui décide de devenir une
république l'an passé en quand William
et Kate sont passés l'an passé il y a eu
beaucoup de manifestations parce que la
question des réparations sur l'esclavage
et dans le présent dans la région chaque
fois que la monarchie de passage donc je
pense qu'au Canada on est loin derrière
le reste sauf que si un mouvement
ailleurs dans le commonnoir pour en
parler je pense que ça va forcer la
question au Canada aussi vous le disiez
la Barbade on va le revoir la Barbade en
2021 2021 et sorti du système
monarchique l'île Maurice également et
il y a des pays du Père Noël qui sont en
processus vous l'avez dit Australie
Jamaïque Nouvelle-Zélande où il y a eu
des des
où on promet donc dans un deuxième
mandat pour ce qui est de l'Australie
d'y voir donc Michel C on sera les
derniers vous êtes d'accord
que ça devienne une question pour de
politique canadienne et qui est parti
qui disent voilà ça va faire nous
n'avons nous n'avons plus les liens que
nous avions avec la Couronne britannique
le nombre de Canadiens d'origine
britannique si je me trompe pas c'est
juste au-dessus de 30% maintenant
avec le nom avec le nombre de nouveaux
arrivants puis tout ça ces gens là ont
pas de lien avec la couronne des
Québécois bien sûr que non alors un
moment donné quelques peu partir avec ce
ballon là ça va être compliqué parce
qu'il faut l'unanimité des provinces et
tout ça mais ça peut se faire à une
condition par exemple c'est que on dise
ok il y aura une ronde constitutionnelle
sur la monarchie et sur rien d'autre on
vient pas avec les revendications
tochtones et puis le pouvoir de dépasser
puis tout ce que vous voulez d'autres
juste la monarchie si quelqu'un courait
avec ce ballon là je pense que ça peut
être payant politiquement Alain
qu'est-ce que le Canada ne pourra pas
faire l'économie de ce débat là
éternellement qu'en pensez-vous
est-ce qu'on peut faire une ronde
constitutionnelle en parlant uniquement
de monarchie c'est là la grande question
est-ce qu'on est prêt dans les
différentes provinces ou les Premières
nations à accepter de nos débattre que
de ça alors qu'il y a plusieurs
insatisfactions avec la avec la
Constitution c'est une bonne question
est-ce qu'on devrait avoir ce débats
bien sûr est-ce qu'on peut laisser dans
les moyens d'y arriver donc on parle
Michel que c'est un peu plus complexe à
mon émission ce midi je recevais Michael
benienne qui est un éditorialiste du
journal Times à Londres journal time ce
qu'on ne peut pas vraiment taxé d'anti
monarchiste là pas du tout lui disait
écouté même la famille royale en réalité
ça les dérange assez peu que les pays
couplent les liens avec la monarchie le
Canada la Nouvelle-Zélande l'Australie
ça fait longtemps qu'on pense que ça va
arriver un jour vous pourriez très bien
vous choisir un chef d'État devenir une
République puis on a sourcéré à peu près
pas à Londres dans les du côté de la
famille royale et même des dirigeants
pourquoi parce que la plupart des pays
sont rendus là par contre ce qu'on
voudrait se garder un lien le prix du
commonweb sont 56 mais il y a une
quinzaine de pays la reine ou le roi
comme chef d’état direct donc si on
garde un lien avec la Couronne
britannique d'une manière un peu floue
comme la commune World organisation je
pense que même eux seraient prêt à ce
qu'on ait ce débat là il semble que ce
soit ici ou on est un peu frileux pour
l'instant là on va écouter monsieur
Trudeau puis après je vais revenir en
détail sur ce que vous décriviez
c'est-à-dire une ronde constitutionnelle
pourquoi diable une ronde conditionnée
on va tout expliquer ça mais d'abord
écoutons monsieur Trudeau qui a
rejeté cette idée quand même assez
clairement
on en a vécu des débats constitutionnels
changer notre système de gouvernement
n'importe quel moment c'est difficile
maintenant on est dans une heure où il y
a des grandes transformations que ce
soit un virage vert que ce soit à la
réalité d'un d'un monde politique
international qui a changé profondément
avec l'invasion de la réussite de
l'Ukraine on est dans tellement un
moment complexe et compliqué que de
faire un changement aussi profond dans
un système qui est parmi les meilleurs
systèmes les plus stables dans le monde
maintenant pour moi c'est pas une bonne
idée
bon on va essayer de décortiquer ça
Émilie Nicolas ce qu'on disait je
commence avec vous le c'est que on doit
remplacer le chef d'État actuellement
qui est la Couronne britannique part une
entité que ce soit un comité
constitutionnel que ça soit le président
de l'Assemblée de la Chambre des
communes que ça soit un Président si on
voulait devenir une république mais on
peut garder la forme parlementaire mais
il faut trouver un chef d'État qui est
au-dessus du Parlement pour que notre
système fonctionne ça se fait ça se
trouve mais ça prendrait forme et
l'unanimité de toutes les provinces ça
prendrait forme ça prend uneanimité de
toutes les provinces ceci dit il y a des
choses qu'on pourrait faire sans sans
aller jusque là déjà par exemple la
monnaie changer changer cette présence
là dans notre quotidien le
serment que les les nouveaux citoyens
canadiens prêtent à la couronne on peut
changer ça ici au Québec ça fait
longtemps que c'est plus le lieu tant
entrepreneurs qui donnent du cours du
trône c'est le premier ministre ça
serait bien peut-être si à Ottawa aussi
plutôt que de se demander ce la
gouvernance générale est capable de
donner de discours du trône en français
en anglais ça c'était c'était le premier
ministre si c'était le premier ministre
qu'il ferait se déballage très réglé
aussi donc il y a des façons de de
réfléchir à la monarchie sans
s'embarquer jusque là si les gens
voulaient mais je pense aussi que une
des raisons pour laquelle le Canada
reste un des derniers dans le commonwald
c'est que il y a beaucoup de Canadiens
d'origine britannique ce sont définies
longtemps en opposition essentiellement
aux Américains qui ont décidé de faire
la révolution contre la colonie
britannique donc c'est comme si ce vieux
fonds loyaliste fait partie des
mythologies nationales canadiennes de
manière que c'est pas le cas en
Australie c'est pas le cas de
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est pas le cas hier
au commonweil donc cette espèce de
position là face aux États-Unis je pense
qu'il va falloir trouver une façon de
remplacer la monarchie si on voulait
sonner là-dedans vers un symbole qui qui
crée pas des crises existentielles chez
les gens qui sont attachés à cette
distinction avec les États-Unis mais je
vous rappelle que même au Canada tout à
l'heure
non diriez-vous que vous êtes
personnellement ta chaîne monarchie non
au Canada c'est 77% absolument
ça augmente avec les gens qui sont issus
de l'immigration du commonweight dans
des pays qui se sont débarrassés de la
monarchie exacte ok Michel sur le sur le
rat on pourrait trouver une entité un
nom d'ailleurs l'Australie jongle avec
plusieurs noms
il y a plein de pays qui font ça il y a
un président d'Allemagne c'est quelqu'un
qui a une fonction essentiellement
horrifique parce qu'il Parlement puis
chancelier qui ont le pouvoir politique
facile ça c'est pas compliqué d'ailleurs
en Australie le référendum avait échoué
parce que la moitié disait non il faut
un président élu l'autre moitié des
républicains disaient non il faut que le
Parlement le choisissent s'il y avait
tous s'il y avait 6 ces amis d'accord là
dessus alors ça c'est pas
extraordinairement compliqué est-ce que
ce qui est difficile c'est d'avoir la
volonté politique de dire on fait cette
honte là on fait pas rien d'autre dans
cette ronde-là mais quand on entame ce
trou nous dire on peut pas toucher à ça
parce que ça fonctionne bien c'est
stable c'est stable si tu veux pas de
changement et la Constitution
canadiendra les changements extrêmement
difficiles mais ça veut pas dire que les
Canadiens ne veulent pas ce changement
là puis ils vont en avoir d'autres des
sondages comme ça au fur et à mesure
qu'on va voir le roi Charles évoluer là
pour sûr que l'affection qui avait pour
la reine pour la personne la reine qui
est derrière
pour le roi Charles parce qu'Alex
il y a quelque chose d'un autre époque
et là maintenant que ils avaient deux là
avec Charles en plus ça va peut-être
accélérer cette réflexion là le rapport
sera pas le même forcément
absolument ça va s'accélérer dans
plusieurs pays et puis je suis d'accord
avec Michel d'une façon assez facile d'y
arriver on pourrait même continuer à
nommer un ou une gouverneur général
nommé au 2/3 par la Chambre des communes
pour être le juge en chef la course
suprême qui a prouve les lois en toute
fin c'est lui qui est ou elle peut
simplement c'est lui qui remplace quand
il y a pas de gouverneur général ça a
été des fois c'était vaccale autant la
question c'est est-ce qu'il y a un parti
politique qui pense que c'est
suffisamment payant pour en faire un
cheval de bataille parce qu'on regarde
les sondages il y a pas de relais
politiques actuellement le NPD n'aime
pas la monarchie il y en parle à peu
près jamais les conservateurs au
contraire sous Steven emploi on en a
fait même quelque chose d'important pour
la tradition canadienne juste un Trudeau
visiblement l'impression que plus on est
âgé plus on est attaché à la monarchie
puis que c'est pas le temps de toucher à
ça les sondages vous conseillerais donc
ça va prendre un parti politique
il y a pas de véhicule actuellement à ce
qui va y en avoir un maintenant
qu'Elisabeth est décédé c'est ça qui va
être intéressant ok il y a le black
québécois mais je peux sûr que c'est la
réforme que les intéresse beaucoup
d'ailleurs le chef du Bloc qui commence
à faire campagne avec le Parti québécois
mais c'est une autre question le tas 2 4
QS je voyais hier dans les bulletins
d'information que les gens prenaient
cette phrase là en disant c'est une
lutte à deux désormais seul plat à bout
du paragraphe selon Gabriel ado Dubois
comme c'était un fait c'est une tactique
politique et employée par Gabriel ado
Dubois et employé par monsieur Legault
on va écouter monsieur Legault et
Gabriel ado Dubois
deux visions très claires qui
s'affrontent qui sont très différents
la nuit dans les quartiers pour aller
mettre des dépliants dans les pare-brise
des gens je trouve ça honnêtement plutôt
drôle je pense pas que c'est le genre de
politique qui va séduire les Québécois
les Québécoises je pense pas que ça va
pas changer d'idées beaucoup de monde
bon il était sur les tracs c'est extrait
là il y a eu des tracts dans la région
de Québec pas dans les gens Québec ici
disons les taxes dénonçant la taxe
orange avec le tas 2
pas ça qu'on voit dans les sondages
Lucas deux peut-être idéologique mais
mathématiques non pas du tout il y a une
dizaine de circonscriptions là où il y a
vraiment le temps de Québec solidaire
laquelle ça revient Québec quelques
circonscriptions sur l'île de Montréal
dans l'esprit un peu dans la région de
Québec Jean le sage mais en réalité
mathématiquement il y a pas de lutte à
deux avec personne dans l'état actuel
des sondages la réalité c'est ça Gabriel
Nadaud Dubois lui veut évidemment
s'imposer pour essayer de fédérer les
insatisfaits ceux qui aiment pas
François Legault en disant voter pour
nous c'est la seule manière que votre
vote va compter c'est généralement
tactique qu'on emploie lorsque on est
deuxième ou troisième puisqu'on veut à
la fin rallier les gens et tu as
peut-être encore un peu tôt pour faire
ça là deux semaines la fin de la
campagne mais je comprends pourquoi le
Québec solidaire veut le faire du côté
de la CAQ c'est uniquement purement
strat le parti que le plus grand
contraste avec lui c'est Québec
solidaire sur un paquet de plans donc
pour
effaroucher un peu on l'utilise comme
épouvantail pourrait faire rocher les
électeurs plus centrés ou de centres
droit on dit ça va être une catastrophe
non donc les deux se retrouvent à
vouloir polariser leur vote c'est pour
ça très bien Michel
c'est Monsieur Lego qui qui fait ça
auprès de ma barre parce que lui ce
qu'il veut c'est dire il y a moins qui
est un modèle qui a lui qui est un
extrémiste si vous votez pas le logo
vous aurez de nado ça c'est j'espère que
ça c'est ça va faire peur au monde pour
pour la route du bois c'est sûr que se
faire dire par le Premier ministre il
est mon adversaire ça lui donne la
statue veut pas et ça permet de et pour
Monsieur Legros ça lui permet d'ignorer
littéralement le Parti libéral le
position qui normalement devrait être le
gouvernement en attente qui est tout
sauf ça dans cette campagne électorale
ici la manga a énormément de difficultés
à percer le mur d'indifférence puis
quand on parle d'hydrogène vers là les
gens disent ouais c'est pour rentrer en
France vous me rappellerez parce que ça
fait ça a pas l'air concret pour les
gens alors effectivement la lutte
biologique est avec le dos du bois mais
les sondages montrent pas ça la réalité
de terrain ne monte pas ça s'il y a des
endroits où c'est de l'eau du bois des
endroits aussi du
des endroits que c'est
QS effectivement il y a des endroits que
c'est même le Parti québécois dans l'Est
du Québec il y a des ans donc c'est
morcelé et parce que Alex c'est
important ce que vous êtes il y a une
dizaine de circonscriptions où il y a
vraiment on ne sait pas entre la CAQ et
le Québec solidaire qui veulent
l'emporter Cherbourg qui est un bon
exemple même saint François côté bon
bref on les fera pas toutes Émilie mais
c'est sûr que ce qu'on voit comment se
sentait s'adapter de la campagne c'était
déjà comme ça à l'Assemblée nationale où
il y avait Dominique Anglade comme chef
de l'opposition officielle mais on
disait on aurait souvent dit dans la
façon dont on parlait de ce qui se
passait à l'Assemblée nationale que
c'était Gabriel Lanaud Dubois contre
François Legault avec des mots souvent
qui ont monté dans la rhétorique là
comme symboliquement qu'on essaie de
d'inciter sur le contraste puis pense
longtemps que c'est une dynamique qui va
avantager les deux politiquesment je
pense qu'on va rester dedans maintenant
c'est sûr que je comprends aussi
Dominique anglaise commandant les autres
chefs de parties de dire attention c'est
pas deux puis ont raison dans les faits
mais dans les faits aussi
malheureusement avec le système
électoral qu'on a si les autres parties
restent aussi divisées même si François
Legault à peu près les mêmes en ce
moment on va voir après après le après
les prochains sondages mais en ce moment
il a à peu près les mêmes le même
pourcentage de votre qu'il avait à
l'élection 2018 mais il semble que si
les choses continuent comme ça il y
aurait plus de compter parce que
l'opposition est tellement divisée comme
ça donc on peut comprendre aussi
quelqu'un comme Gabriel dans notre voix
mais aussi quelqu'un comme n'importe
quel autre comme de mieux que Anglade ou
les autres de vouloir être de commencer
peut-être à vouloir faire des
ralliements stratégiques des appels au
vote stratégique pour se sortir de cette
division là oui profit de la division
c'est clair si le PQ Québec solidaire et
ne formait qu'un parti ne je vous parle
de politique fiction mais
c'est peut-être qu'on va reparler plus
sérieusement un jour mais donc là il y
aurait bon
le troisième lien je commence avec vous
Emilie rapidement non je vais commencer
avec un extrait de monsieur duem qui ce
matin alors a voulu faire un autre tour
de roue là dessus en disant moi je vais
demander les études bon on les avait
tous demandés en passant là tous les
médias en fait toutes les demandes
possibles mais on écoute que ça donne
avec Monsieur Lego qui répond
on souhaite avoir l'information il reste
14 jours très exactement aujourd'hui
avant le moment où les Québécois vont se
pointer aux urnes les gens de Québec
vous savez c'est le plus gros
investissement de l'histoire de la ville
les gens de Québec sont en droit de
savoir ce qui se passe c'est la question
de l'une pour plusieurs personnes dans
la région de Québec
il y a des études qui sont en cours
quand elles vont être terminées elles
vont être publiées
François Legault se moque de la science
ce manque de se moque des rapports puis
se moque des Québécois
on le fait qu'il y a plus depuis
longtemps et bonne chance pour les
recevoir en 14 jours en passant et puis
laisse un peu plus longs
moi ce que je pense c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont fait leur tête
sur le troisième lien il aime ou il
l'aime pas son d'accord ou non et qu'il
y a pas mal de gens qui ne vont parler
dans le terme d'intervention de vote le
nouveau pas changer d'idées sur cette
question là pour François Legault
comment c'est un peu embarrassant c'est
ce qu'il est transparent ou non à ce
qu'on cache des études ça c'est moins
clair mais sur le projet lui-même je ne
vois pas de mouvement important dans les
deux prochaines semaines l'opinion
publique est pas mal arrêté pour
l'instant sur ce sujet dans la région de
Québec beaucoup plus Michel sait même
pas
il rendu à sa quatrième version monsieur
Legault sur cette histoire là il y avait
des études sont pas bonnes il y a le
télétravail après ça c'est autre chose
et là aujourd'hui c'est quelques soit
les études de la décision et politique
donc on n'a pas besoin un moment donné
ça ça lui ça ça lui a l'air de cacher
quelque chose mais
la réalité c'est qu'il y en a des études
entre autres sur l'impact des grands
projets sur l'état-maurbain ça il veut
pas les rendre publics sont ici alors ça
c'est un problème pour lui c'est un
problème qui touche sa crédibilité qui
va bien plus loin que le troisième lien
et c'est ça qui peut lui faire mal il
faudra voir maintenant comment ça
s'articule dans les contextes à Québec
mais à un moment donné le premier
ministre dit j'ai une étude puis je vous
la montrerai pas ça c'est la version 3
de ce qui a dit sur le troisième lieu
cette semaine ça l'estonne merci
beaucoup à vous trois bonnes suite moi
je vais disparaître quelques jours pour
réapparaître jeudi soir alors bonne
suite et à très bientôt au revoir au
revoir bonsoir